the hits seem poised to keep on coming
because now this term the Supreme Court
is going to take on another major social
question that conservatives have fought
in vain for for many decades and that
even conservative appointments
and the court people like Sandra Day
O'Connor and other people have kind of
squished on and so our hopes have been
dashed on this before The Supreme Court
is going to take up the question of
racial discrimination in college
admissions better known as affirmative
action
but the idea that certain students will
not get into college because of their
race and other students will have an
unfair advantage in getting into college
because of their race there's really
really good news on this front the
Supreme Court just heard oral arguments
in two cases taking on affirmative
action in college yesterday and the
signs are very very promising
so the Supreme Court hears the the
oral arguments yesterday in these two
cases about affirmative action in
college being brought by a legal group
that is challenging this on behalf of
Asian students you know Asian students
and white students are put at a
disadvantage and black students and
Hispanic students get an advantage now
we have a conservative court it's at
least a 5-4 conservative Corpus Roberts
is uh squish who will usually side with
the Liberals on really contentious
issues but you've still got then five
four you know you can at least kind of
count on the conservative court and then
there's even better news because the
newest just Justice at katanji Jackson
the Justice who doesn't know what a
woman is she's had to recuse herself
from these cases because one of the
cases involves Harvard and she was just
recently on one of the boards at Harvard
and so it's a conflict of interest so
she's out so the deck is even more in
the the Stacked in the direction of the
conservatives
there there was an amazing uh
poll that was done uh poll Pew research
hold Americans and said should race and
ethnicity be a factor in admissions 75
three quarters of Americans say no
absolutely not
and don't forget the Supreme Court
watches the polls the Supreme Court
reads the newspapers
so the the fact that public opinion is
now with the conservatives and with
Justice when we're talking about
affirmative action this is a really
really good sign
so the cases are students for fair
admissions versus Harvard and students
for fair admissions versus the
University of North Carolina
the most telling part of the oral
arguments yesterday was when
Clarence Thomas the OG the Mack Daddy on
the court Mr Conservative oldest
conservative member there was was
grilling the lawyer for UNC about
diversity
because the libs say we need affirmative
action because we need diversity because
diversity is really good for education
and so it's in the interest of the
university to have
diversity by which they mean giving
extra points to black students and
taking points away from Asians and
whites and Clarence Thomas
black man on the court can't it's very
difficult to call the guy racist he says
okay judge I'm following your line of
argument
now what is your or um okay Council okay
lawyer for UNC I'm following your line
of argument
now what is the evidence that diversity
is good
for education
here's the question
uh Mr Park um I've heard the word uh
diversity quite a few times and I don't
have a clue what it means
uh it seems to mean everything for
everyone
uh the and I'd like you first you did
give some examples in your opening
remarks
but I'd like you to give us a specific
definition of diversity in the context
of the University of North Carolina
and I'd also like you to give us a a
clear idea of exactly
uh what the educational benefits of
diversity at the University of North
Carolina would be
so Clarence Thomas very good lawyer he
says look this word diversity is really
slippery so I need you to give me a
definition of what diversity actually
means because I can't quite nail it down
and then after that I don't want to hear
about the social benefits of diversity
the political benefits of diversity I
don't want to hear about the benefits to
the black students or the Asian students
or obviously doesn't benefit the Asians
very well or anything else
I want you to tell me
what educational purpose is served by
diversity now this should be a layup
if
the UNC and Harvard have any case at all
for their their unjust racial
discriminatory practices in college
admissions this should have been the
first answer that they figure out and
memorize it should be so easy right
but here's the answer
yes your honor so first we Define
diversity the way this court has in its
Court's precedence which means a broadly
diverse set of criteria that extends to
all different backgrounds and
perspectives and not solely limited to
race and there's a factual finding in
this record pet app 113 that there are
many different diversity factors that
are considered as a greater factor in
our admissions process than race on the
educational benefits question your honor
I don't think it's actually disputed
here that there are real and meaningful
educational benefits that come with
diversity of all kinds sfa's own expert
this is on ja 546 conceded and agreed
enthusiastically in fact on the stand
that a racially diverse and a diverse
diversity of all kinds leads to quote a
deeper and richer learning environment
leads to more creative thinking and
exchange of ideas and critically reduce
bias between people of different
backgrounds and not solely different
racial backgrounds
uh but you still haven't given me the
educational benefits
you love
love Clarence Thomas there just in that
really slow plotting it's he's almost
like the Norm Macdonald of the Court
which is that he's an extremely
intelligent man but he kind of plays
dumb sometimes and it's Scalia did this
to some degree as well
so he says okay it's a simple question
what's the educational benefit of
diversity
and the lawyer says well there's
actually a total consensus among all the
really smart fancy people that diversity
is really really good and they all say
that it's really really good and they've
said for years actually that diversity
is really really good and that's why
diversity is really really good for
education
and Clarence Thomas
um
maybe I'm a little slow maybe I'm a
little thick I don't know but uh
you didn't answer the question you're
telling me that other people agree with
you but you're not telling me why you're
not presenting any sort of evidence even
the definition of diversity he doesn't
really address he just says a lot of
jargon and gobbled ego and says well
there's all different types of diversity
I think Clarence Thomas
I I hope he never retires from the court
if he does he's got to come straight to
daily wire so we can make a walsh-esque
movie what is diversity
there's what is a woman starring Walsh
what is diversity starring Clarence
Thomas the answers are going to be
completely nonsensical in both
this was really devastating I think to
the UNC and Harvard and pro-affirmative
action argument here on their most basic
question they don't have an answer what
good is diversity
in education for Education they don't
have an answer
because the answer is obvious
diversity in itself is not always or
even often a good thing why explain to
me why diversity
take the word however you want to take
it because it's hard to pin down like
Clarence Thomas says why is diversity a
good thing
is the on our money does it say out of
many
even many different things out of many
more out of many
far greater distinction and difference
and individualism no it says Unum out of
many one
we are not the diverse States of America
we are the United States of America
Unity is a strength
diversity is not a strength it's a
weakness
so
when when you bring in people of
different backgrounds or different
experiences or different what whatever
that can be all well and good but it it
has to it has to come with a Unity so if
we're going to have a country made up of
lots of different types of people we
need to all speak the same language we
have to broadly believe the same things
we have to be engaged in the same common
Endeavor we have to recognize the same
common good in a university you can
bring in people of any kinds of
background if you like but this is the
very point of the university the
university is supposed to bring you all
together for the single-minded pursuit
of truth that's why it's a university
it's not a DOT it's not a diversity it's
a university it's right there in the
very word
absolutely devastating to the case and
and so I think if the
if the UNC and Harvard team can't muster
better arguments than that
hard to see how affirmative action
survives 2023 really really good news to
look forward to so we've got the love
don't judge challenge today
it's very spooky It's a Spooky post
Halloween love don't judge challenge uh
the rest of the show is continuing now
you do not want to miss this if you are
not a member click the link in the
description and join us
foreign
[Music]
[Music]